let me uh
because when you were talking so
romantically and passionately about io
i remember the the poem by robert frost
so let me ask you uh
let me read the poem and ask what your
opinion
is that's called fire and ice oh yeah i
could almost recite this from memory
some say the world will end in fire some
saying ice
from what i've tasted of desire hold
with those who favor fire
but if i had to perish twice i think i
know enough of hate
to say that for destruction ice is also
great
and will suffice so uh let me ask
if you had to only choose one would you
choose the world to end in fire
in volcanic eruptions in heat
and magma or in ice
frozen over fire ice
fire
excellent choice the sort of
i i've always been a fan of chaos and
uh the idea of things just
slowly getting cold and stopping and
dying
is just so depressing to me so much more
depressing than things
blowing up or you know burning or
getting covered by a lava flow somehow
the like activity of it
endows it with more like meaning to me
maybe
i've some i've just now had this vision
of you you know in action films where
you're walking away without looking back
and there's explosions behind you
and you just got and you put on like
shades and then it goes to credits so
um katherine this was awesome i think
your work is really
inspiring the
the kind of things we'll discover about
planets in the next few decades is super
cool and i hope
i know you said there's probably not
life in one of them but there might be
and i i hope we discover just that and
perhaps even on io within the volcanic
eruptions there's a
there's a little creature hanging on
that will one day discover
thank you so much for wasting all your
valuable time with me today it was
really it was really awesome
yeah likewise thank you for having me
here
you